اغنيه ادتها الفنانه بسمه بوسيل في حفل
زفاف اثارت ازمه
وفي بدايه حفل زفاف الممثله المصريه ميرنا
نور الدين توجهت بوسيل الى العروسين مغنيه
لهما مين اللي بيختار وهي اغنيه للفنانه
اللبنانيه
وتحول الامر الى جلسات محاكمه متبادله حول
حقوق النشر والتوزيع وتمت المطالبه
بالتوقف عن اداء الاغنيه كما هي وتغيير
بياناتها
وكانت شركه وطريقه شاركت بيانا على تويتر
اعتبرت فيه ان الفنانه المغربيه بسمه
بوسيل تعدت على حقوقهما فور جي والكاتب
غدير الرحباني والملحن الموسيقي قوسان
الرحباني لعدم مراعاتها حقوق الملكيه
الادبيه والفنيه والفكريه الخاصه بالاغنيه
[موسيقى]
واكدت الشركه ان بسمه خالفت القوانين
لانها نشرت الكفر الخاص بالاغنيه على
حسابها في انستجرام دون ان تذكر عنوان
الاغنيه ودون ان تذكر انها لتلك الاغنيه
ودون ان تذكر اسماء اصحاب الحقوق
الاساسيين في تعد صارخ على حقوق المعنويه
حيث كان يجري بها ذكرهم بالتفصيل
[موسيقى]